[Music]
you have a 15 year old son yes his name
is Kevin jr. okay what kind of mommy I'm
just thinking like Wendy Williams the
mom I'm trying to imagine you at home
what what are the rules at home are you
pretty loose about stuff be pretty are
you an uptight mom I'm kind of turning
into my own mother I find myself
screeching and yelling a lot now that
he's 15 I'm loose in some ways and
uptight and others like we don't close
doors at our house there was no need for
him to be in his room with the door
closed actually there there actually is
I was a 15 year old boy the same thing
with 15 year old girls I know what
you're talking about but here's the deal
we walk hard in our house and that way
or we're always clearing our throats
that's the warning sign that here I come
you don't just tiptoe to somebody's room
I respect him so when I come to see his
room you hear it or am Kevin here I come
right and I and I walk over to give him
a chance to clean up and we don't close
our door either but if you walk in on me
and my husband you're gonna get a
surprise as that has that happened with
your son once three uh when he was 13
okay can you tell us what happened no
but but I'll just tell you this he got a
surprise and he will never do that again
well I think it's fair for me to know
what the surprise was your honor
you're on a talk show and you have a
talk show yeah you know the rules so but
late what the hell did he walk in on
giving my husband a favor at two o'clock
in the morning two o'clock in the
morning yes oh my god you guys must've
had a lot of coffee
what do you add to it I mean you know
the hours are weird okay yeah okay so he
walked in on you doing that yes and he
forgot to clear his throat and stop yeah
well well what did he think was going on
well he didn't hear anything we saw the
TV and then he looked and what do you
think we did continued that'll you
continue wait wait wait wait wait
leaving you continued Connie looked over
and you were like that and then you
wanting to continue maybe my husband
went like this but the next day he was
going out you know with some of his
friends and I usually we leave the house
with a hug and a kiss he hugged but he
wouldn't kiss me yeah these are charming
stories but listen how is he now was he
at all I mean that would that would that
would blow a kid's mind I would think
that was just rude settle down I would
need years and years of therapy you
sound like your kid was fine because we
come from a different generation these
kids these days this it's kind of early
our son I guess it's very chill in a lot
of ways you know what I mean like yeah
we've never had the conversation about
it and in my mind if we ever do have it
it's I'm gonna lead with will at least
your mother and father love each other
yes more than I can say for some of the
kids that you know that you're growing
up with don't enjoy that yeah we would
just show him this tape you don't have
to talk to him about it you've talked
about it now so you're all set just you
know pop the tape in you're all good
well
you